welcome to this video playing Grand
Master's yeah Dean off from Uzbekistan
I'm trying to get a free dog but he
tends to play quite original openings
you never know what is going to do so
that we get a free dog jobie tool so
slightly slightly unambitious normally
it goes to see four but it's not it's
not terrible it's just a bit tame yep
try to play be five and the no run okay
night to see form maybe he wants to even
play F for possible
ok so now I fall at least not in the
near future ok like to cavity 5 and d6
that's so 96 this is a strange move yeah
I don't really understand night I see
not be six but this is just a misplaced
piece that can add best now exchange on
this haven't if he doesn't exchange a
plane ride see five or something and let
it just hang let it yeah let it be on b6
and doesn't do anything if I was a very
strange move I think black already is in
excellent shape here I play threaten 95
winning me for and so yeah he needs to
needs to care about that 95 yeah it's
still it's still a good move I threaten
90 form anyway and also be four and
taking e4 also the many ways to to a win
material there's also night to e6 and to
d4 as a possibility many good ideas okay
but as this is actually nice night to d4
and possibly Bishop c5 attacking the sir
this night possibly just winning upon
like 94 then Bishop c5 threatens Bishop
takes b6 and just winced the pawn yeah
this is a terrible position four ID
if I've was just a very very strange
move yeah what the heck is he doing here
yeah this is just just suicidal giving
up f4 in the process and now each was
hanging get these in desperation mode
here
Leah slight chance to serve some counter
play on the King side okay let's get
this night back into plain
yeah I have played a number of games
against him and he's a very original
player sometimes he's really playing
creative interesting chess and sometimes
it just doesn't work out at all like in
this game where he is just busted not
only need to be careful not to to
blunder some material but that's the
only only way to not win it here I'm
trying to keep their foursquare but in
both nights covering the square can i
also have g6 if he tries to attack the
night like Queen g46 and my next idea is
Queenie 7 and Queen h4 swinging the
Queen over note that is always playing
with them without this night it's just
quite severe to being a piece down this
night on g3 know okay so Queen Anne IG
595 there's only Queen g4
hmm
okay many many good ways to play this I
only shouldn't take too long and then
get into the big time trouble okay okay
come on keep it simple exchanging
quinces easy and simple to play I
already have have an extra porn on on g6
and he's got a terrible position with TT
pawns the basically not exist existing
nighataan v6 the bed bishops and bishop
and so on okay here i can go here you
why not taking me for check okay if i go
nite c5 bishop g6 Jim bishop g6 is not
really a threat okay let's activate this
c4 threatened I know the night gets a
possible square on d5 but the long
diagonal is also nothing to be nothing
to do it to underestimate very nice
yeah there's still no threat
look h1 I do 95-93 coming
yeah it's simply all the time the night
on b6 is just is just am NOT playing the
only a sound check now
yes someone there's a clock white
foreheads aren't I like a problem here
yeah I think white was basically
struggling to stay in the game after the
movie 50 this is a bit passive for white
but nothing spectacularly bad but if I
versus just a very strange move yeah
because this is just a very bad piece it
has nowhere to go it doesn't take
anything and it doesn't control any
vital square so it's just something I
can I can play around the only thing
what you should do he has probably just
take on d7 played this one this is I
think even worse but he should he should
probably take and then I have more than
one good option Knight takes it's not
bad also rook takes Queen and see 5 i'm
attacking e4 threatening also be four or
c4 c4 Bishop c5 it's very comfortable a5
is just not not helping in any way it's
just a weakness on a 5 also then the
game at was I think even worse after 95
and 96 Black is basically winning but
g4s of course um yeah very young very
weakening move alright thanks for
watching